Speaker 1: According to a new poll, a majority
of Americans, including a large percentage
of non vaccinated Americans, actually are
OK with vaccine mandates.
This is remarkable.
Here it is, according to a late July morning
consult poll.
Fifty six percent of adults said employers
should probably or definitely require covid-19
vaccinations for their employees and customers.
Only 32 percent said they probably or definitely
should not.
That confidence extends to schools to.
Last month, Gallup found that 60 percent of
Americans supported mandatory vaccines for
high school students and 56 percent supported
them for middle school students.
Although among K through 12 parents, those
numbers were notably lower 47 percent and
43 percent respectively.
And 28 percent of unvaccinated people actually
support mandatory vaccines.
So all this fear mongering that we see.
Coming from the right, mostly, there is still
some coming from some folks who claim to be
on the left, but.
It's all for lack of a better term nonsense,
it's B.S.
We don't want mass mandates, actually look
at the polls, people do.
They're OK with it.
They don't see it as a violation of their
freedom.
They see it as protecting other people.
Hell, when you have twenty eight percent of
people who aren't even vaccinated yet saying,
yes, this thing should be mandatory, that
tells you a lot here.
And unfortunately, that is probably where
we're headed.
I say, unfortunately, because there are still
people who are hugely against this.
And I wish we honestly didn't have to get
to the point where we had to mandate this
thing.
But too many people fell for the misinformation,
too many people fell for the lies, and so
now here we are.
It would have been great if we had every eligible
and healthy enough person, because that's
an important distinction to make.
Who was able to get the vaccine if they had
gotten the vaccine?
And we wouldn't even be talking about a Delta
variant today, maybe.
And about that distinction real quick, because
I do want to point out, yes, there are plenty
of people here in the United States who are
physically incapable of getting that vaccine,
you know, immunocompromised people, people
allergic to some of the things in the vaccine
so they can't get it.
And trust me, whenever I talk about things
like this, I'm not saying you guys should
have to get it at all.
You can not.
It puts you in danger when you get the vaccine.
So even if we ended up with any kind of vaccine
mandates, I think they would definitely have
to carve out that exception for those individuals.
But if it's just somebody who says, no, I
don't want to get it because I saw a video
and a woman said it made her magnetic.
OK, you know what, that's not a valid reason,
because that's not actually a thing that happened.
And I'm sure we've all seen that video from
from Ohio where they were having the hearing
and the woman came in and said, look, even
my keys stick to me.
And then the key didn't then stick to her
because she's not magnetic.
And I think David actually pointed out on
social media, has anybody even thought about
maybe being magnetic isn't that bad?
You know what what really is the drawback
to that?
It was humorous, of course, but here's the
thing, and this isn't so funny.
We're at a point.
Were most people in this country who are of
eligible age?
There's no longer the long lines, there's
no longer the fight to get in to get the vaccine,
they're open.
You can go to most pharmacies here in the
United States.
If if there is a line, you're going to wait
a couple of minutes and you can go and get
this vaccine.
It's it really is that simple for those who
are eligible and are not in any kind of danger
when receiving the vaccine.
That's where we're at.
And most Americans understand that, and I
think that's why these poll numbers are the
way that they are.
Because people see, you know what, we could
be getting this, yes, covid is getting worse
and I see that now.
Not to mention, of course, all of the stories
that we've seen of people who didn't get vaccinated
then died.
And unfortunately, we have another one
of those